figuerola y bonjour on va parler ce
lundi matin de la situation en ukraine
bien évidemment je suis avec eux fabrice
nodé langlois journaliste économie
internationale au figaro et ancien
correspondant à moscou pour le figaro
bonjour fabrice bonjour vincent avec
vous on va décrypter un peu la situation
ce qui se passe en ce moment l'impact
est effectivement des sanctions
économiques puisque le monde de
l'économie internationale est en train
de bouillonner en sort en ce début de
semaine et bien sûr ce toulon cela il
vous n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions on va essayer d'y répondre au
mieux possible on peut peut-être faire
un petit point sur l'information du jour
c'est ces corridors humanitaires proposé
par la russie fabrice oui alors une
demande formulée par emmanuel macron
d'essayer d'ouvrir des corridors
humanitaires pour évacuer notamment les
civils de marioupol par exemple de
karkhiv aux dernières nouvelles la
l'ukraine opposé une fin de non recevoir
s'il faut dire que la russie a fait une
proposition assez particulière elle
propose est d'évacuer les civils n'ont
pas vers l'ouest de l'ukraine mais vers
la russie et vers la biélorussie voisine
donc pour kiev s'est clairement
inacceptable donc on en est là aux
dernières nouvelles qui bouge évidemment
d'heure en heure était matériellement
manifestement d'après les sources
ukrainienne relayée par les agences de
presse ces corridors ne sont pas
matérialisées nous ne sont pas ouverts à
l'heure où nous parlons effectivement
donc on va nous intéresser plutôt à la
partie économique de ce clip de ce qui
se passe en ce moment
peut-être un petit point sur les sur les
sur le jeu sur les bourses ce matin qui
ont qui ont ouvert en chute libre oui de
nouveau une semaine qui commence
vraiment dans le rouge là le cac 40 et
est en train de chuter de plus de 3%
après une série quand même de journée
rouge la semaine dernière j'ai regardé
en fait là le cac 40 vient d'effacer un
an de gains l'année 2021 avait une année
de reprise avec une bourse qui se
portait bien les grands groupes français
qui ont tous affiché des bons résultats
sous sur fond de reprise économique
mondiale est là donc une année de gains
cet été c'est en quelques jours en dix
jours de guerre en ukraine donc
effectivement une des nouvelles de ce
matin c'est les bourses pour la plupart
en asie en europe sont toutes dans le
rouge et puis de nouveau sur l'énergie
ça s'affole
le pétrole flambe de nouveau dimanche il
a frôlé les 140 dollars le baril on est
tout près du record historique absolu
qui lie dette de l'été 2008 où le baril
de brent avait atteint 147 dollars
alors il ya le pétrole qui forme mais le
gaz aussi de nouveau sur les marchés au
comptant il a pulvérisé des records et
puis l'électricité aussi qui se négocie
sur le marché de gros en europe est
aussi à des prix extrêmement élevé est
ce qu'on peut s'attendre justement à ce
que ces prix continuent de continue de
grimper au fur et à mesure que le
conflit prend de l'ampleur alors on a
l'air de s'acheminer vers un conflit qui
pourrait durer évidemment personne n'en
sait rien mais la plupart des
spécialistes qu'il soit militaire ou
économique ne vois pas du tout une crise
qu'ils n'oublieraient au bout de 15
jours je viens de parler un spécialiste
du marché pétrolier
qui pensent qu'on va s'installer dans
une crise dans la durée alors s'agissant
du pétrole effectivement de prix qui
devrait rester durablement très élevé
donc avec des conséquences économiques
pour pour tous tous les acheteurs de
pétrole qui sont les entreprises tout le
tout le secteur de la chimie basé sur le
pétrole le plastique et puis évidemment
en bout de chaîne le l'automobiliste
vous et moi si vous avez une voiture les
prix à la pompe qui vont continuer
d'augmenter même si en france quand vous
avez par exemple 20%
disons 10 % de hausse du baril vous
n'allez pas avoir immédiatement 10% de
hausse
du prix du litre de carburant puisque
deux tiers du prix du litre est composé
de taxes de taxes alors on râle souvent
contre cette taxe mais finalement ils
les auront paradoxalement un effet
amortisseur sur l'augmentation du coup
elle peut elle vous permettre de le
d'amortir et mais on pourrait tout de
même à arriver à ce litre d'essence à 2
euros bientôt dernière clairement alors
on n'est pas à deux euros en moyenne
france le prix qui est calculé chaque
semaine par le mit terre de la
transition écologique mais clairement à
paris sur les autoroutes le super est
allègrement j'ai vu ce week-end du 2
euros 15 / sur une autoroute on a
largement franchi les 2 euros le pour le
plein de simples en 98 on à françois
dans les commentaires qui nous dit merci
pour ce dialogue très clair on va
essayer de vous expliquer au mieux ce
qui se passe nous c'est notre but
effectivement on parlait aussi des
autres matières premières le gaz il est
aussi l'or c'est un peu on pouvait
s'attendre
à quelque chose comme ça alors
je crois que personne ne s'attendait à
rien puisque tout le monde a été surpris
par l'ampleur de cette offensive par
contre il ya des mécanismes assez
classique dans ce genre de crise et
notamment la flambée de l'or alors là
c'est pas parce que tout d'un coup on
n'aurait plus besoin d'or ou parce que
leur viendrait à manquer même si la
russie est un producteur important le ce
qui se passe sur sur l'or c'est très
classique dans l'écrit l'eau redevient
une valeur refuge et des investisseurs
ça peut être des particuliers mais c'est
aussi beaucoup d investisseurs
institutionnels
achètent de l'or parce qu'on sait que
c'est une valeur sûre qui va pas
fluctuer comme comme certaines monnaies
ou autres actifs les actions de
certaines entreprises exposées à la
russie exposé
des secteurs en difficulté vont jouer
les montagnes russes au mauvais jeu de
mots alors que l'or en général est
vraiment une valeur refuge très
classique donc c'est pour ça que que
l'or flambe on parlait justement des
deux de ses entreprises françaises il ya
des entreprises françaises qui sont
impliqués directement qui reste en
russie les sanctions économiques contre
la russie les fragilisent oui alors
quasi la quasi-totalité du cac 40 est
présente en russie soit par des
investissements importants soit au moins
avec des filiales il y à peu près 1200
entreprises donc en comptant les
entreprises de taille plus modeste
présente en russie parfois certaines
depuis alors sois même depuis l'époque
soviétique en tout cas depuis le début
des années 90 avec quelques centaines
d'expatriés plusieurs milliers
d'expatriés actuellement qui ont fait
leur vie parfois à moscou et dans les
grandes villes
parce que c'est un marché prometteur en
pleine expansion à l'orée des années
2000 après la grosse crise des années 90
alors certaines entreprises ces derniers
jours ont décidé volontairement de se
retirer du marché russe c'est notamment
le cas du luxe avec hermès avec lvmh
avec chanel qui purement et simplement
ont fermé leurs boutiques parce que ça
devient compliqué même en en termes de
réputation de de continuer à commercer
en 1060 d'image en fait c'est une
question d'image parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu de d'interdiction de la part des
gouvernements occidentaux à ces groupes
de commercer alors il anticipe aussi
peut-être les contres sanctions rue ce
qu'on attend d'un jour à l'autre dont on
ne sait pas exactement
quelle forme elles vont prendre si ce
n'est qu'il ya eu quand même quelques
informations ce week-end où les
autorités russes ont dit qu'il durait
plusieurs solutions pour les groupes des
pays hostiles s'étaient les termes les
termes des autorités russes qui menaçait
notamment éventuellement des des mises
en faillite forcée des groupes français
par exemple ou des des cessions à des
investisseurs russes en fait donc la
plupart des entreprises russes risquent
de passer deux françaises pardon
expatriés risque de passer un mauvais
quart d'heure dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'avec un groupe comme renault
par exemple soit enfin la branche russe
de renault soit récupéré par le pouvoir
ça peut faire partie des contres
sanction 1 renault est actionnaire de
avtovaz comme le grand constructeur
russe qui commercialise et fabrique la
marque lada donc c'est un marché
important
rien n'est exclu à ce stade l'état russe
pourrait dire 'ok je récupère toutes les
parts dans le cadre de contre sanctions
ces sanctions économiques justement il y
en a eu énormément qui ont indiqué
qu'ils ont déjà été prises ces deux
dernières semaines il y en a qui peuvent
encore être prises dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains jours à
venir oui alors la question suivante c
est ce qu il va y avoir un embargo
finalement sur le pétrole et le gaz
russe parce que ce serait l'armé ultime
à leurs armes vraiment à double
tranchant à la fois sa assécherait les
finances russe
leurs exportations un embargo à burgos
et l'interdiction c'est à dire et c'est
ce que poussent actuellement washington
anthony blinken le secrétaire d'état
américain est en train de faire une
tournée des capitales européennes ils
essayent de convaincre les pays de dire
n'achetez plus du pétrole russe c'est à
dire c'est que les états unis ont fait à
l'égard de l'iran ça fait vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à l'économie
iranienne ces dernières années
évidemment c'est à double tranchant
puisque les pays importateurs ont besoin
de des ressources russes l'allemagne
importe à peu près un tiers de son
pétrole de russie s'agissant de la
france on est moins exposé puisque c'est
un petit peu moins de 10% mais enfin si
on enlevait du jour au lendemain 10 % de
nos besoins de pétrole il faut le temps
de se retourner vers d'autres
producteurs qui ne sont pas forcément
les marges de manoeuvre pour augmenter
leur production pour livrer davantage
donc ça va se traduire de toute façon
par une forte hausse des prix
l'allemagne justement a
indiqué théaux est opposée à cet embargo
sur le gaz le pétrole et le charbon
puisque c'est quelque chose qui pour eux
ce que comme vous lisiez c est très
compliqué de de se retourner et trouver
un nouvel acheteur et surtout acheter
plus cher dans ces conditions c'est tout
le drame de de l'europe qui est très
dépendante de l'énergie russe et alors
du point de vue russe aussi serein un
embargo serait quand même assez
pour être lourd de conséquences on a
énormément parlé ces dernières semaines
du gaz russe mais il faut savoir que les
exportations de gaz russe représente à
peu près 50 milliards de dollars par an
pour la russie le pétrole s'est presse
c'est plus de trois fois plus en fait et
on n'a pas toujours ça en tête c'est
environ 110 milliards de dollars pour le
pétrole brut mais la russie exporte
aussi beaucoup de produits raffinés un
des carburants ou des produits pour la
pétrochimie à hauteur de 80 milliards de
dollars donc c'est en tout 180 milliards
de dollars de recettes d'exportation de
pétrole et peau du produit pétrolier
pour la russie comparez avec 50
milliards pour le gaz donc larmes
pétrolières pourraient faire vraiment
très très mal mais encore une fois très
mal à la puissance exportatrice russie
mais aussi à tous les acheteurs
dont l'europe parce que l'idée c'est de
voir s'effondrer l'économie russe grâce
à ces sanctions c'est d'arriver à
retourner le peuple russe contre vladmir
poutine oui alors bruno le maire a été
réprimandé il est compris par l'elysée
quand la semaine dernière il a utilisé
le terme de guerre économique mais ne
soyons pas hypocrites au fond quand on
prend des sanctions
économiques aussi massive on est bien
dans une guerre économique et rompront
on procède on mène une guerre économique
parce que pour l'instant on n'a pas
envie de mener une guerre militaire
parce qu'on sait qu'elle serait
absolument terrible l'otan a encore dit
ce week-end qui ne l'est pas
participer à une no fly zone à une
interdiction
de
contrôle du ciel ukrainien pas ce que ça
veut dire un affrontement direct avec
l'aviation russe est donc une
confrontation majeure direct entre
l'otan et la russie potentiellement
nucléaire donc si on mène pas de guerre
militaire et ben on mène une guerre
économique et voilà et c'est
effectivement cette escalade que veulent
que veulent éviter que vous évitez de
l'otan justement sur ces sur cette
question
les
le pardon excusez moi je suis un peu
perdu mon fils c'est cette escalade de
ces
sanctions pardon excusez moi contre le
contrôle contre regarder le pétrole on
disait c'est très important pour la
russie et ça pourrait faire retomber la
russie dans un marasme économique oui
alors de toute façon avec ce qui se
passe l'économie russe va de toute façon
souffrir avec le les sanctions bancaires
même si elle ne touche pas toutes les
banques justement elles ont épargné les
banques qui permettent à la russie
d'exporter son gaz et son pétrole donc
il y avait de gros trous dans la
raquette mais enfin ça fait quand même
ça fait quand même mal toutes les
sanctions contre les oligarques et
toutes les personnes vont peut-être pas
freiné l'économie directement mais vont
gêner tous ses dirigeants donc de toutes
façons l'économie russe va de toute
façon va souffrir
les oligarques on en a parlé aussi sur
les sur les fameux yacht l'équité qui
ont été saisis dans dans différentes des
genres pays européens c'est une vraie
stratégie aussi d'arriver à toucher ses
oligarques et non pas et moi le peuple
russe oui alors touché les oligarques
c'est essayer de deux de faire en sorte
que peut-être il lâche où ils suivent -
vladimir poutine même si pour l'instant
il tient tout cette pyramide je pense
d'une main de fer il ya une vraie une
vraie terreur quelque part les
oligarques ne lâcheront pas comme ça et
on avait vu sept cette humiliation
publique au conseil de sécurité
il y a quinze jours et qui montrèrent là
c'était pas vis-à-vis des oligarques
mais qui montrait que poutine exerce une
vraie heures à l'égard de ses
subordonnés donc toucher les oligarques
c'est essayer
de faire en sorte que l'entourage de
poutine le soutiennent - et c'est bon
c'est relativement hasardeuse mais de
toutes façons de la population russe est
déjà touchée avec via l'inflation le
rouble s'effondre donc ça veut dire que
tous les produits importés
vont vite devenir plus chers fin
certains le sont déjà ou alors ça veut
dire que l'état doit subventionner ce
qui coûte cher aux finances publiques
donc de toute façon là la population
russe
n'est pas épargné on a 100 perd events
dans les commentaires qui nous dit est
ce qu'on peut faire un embargo plus
totale sur la russie c'est un fait ce
que réclament les états unis alors c'est
vrai que les états unis réclame un
embargo sur le pétrole et le gaz on
pourrait
l'élargir à d'autres matières premières
différents métaux
là encore c'est comme certains
responsables ont dit si on mène ce genre
de sanction il ya un prix à payer fort
pour ceux qui qui sont à l'origine des
sanctions en l'occurrence les européens
qui serait aux premières lignes en
première ligne si on n'a plus accès à
des métaux stratégiques pour notre
industrie
électroniques pour l'automobile
plus accès évidemment au pétrole et au
gaz les pays à l'origine des sanctions
souffriront aussi son ce sera désastreux
pour l'économie monde et on a une autre
question de 200 caravanes qui demande
est fermée les relations diplomatiques
et renvoyer les ambassadeurs on n'y est
pas encore mais c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait arriver oui alors mitri
medvedev l'ancien président russe qui
avait été fait cet intérim très baroque
en 2008 et qui est toujours au conseil
de sécurité qui est vice-président du
conseil de sécurité de la russie
qui avait réagi justement ces propos de
bruno le maire sur une guerre économique
vie non mais on peut aussi tout à fait
couper les relations diplomatiques les
relations elles finiront par par se
faire uniquement à travers le viseur il
a tenu ces propos c'est fou pour la part
d'un ancien président
au point où on en est on pourrait dire
renoncer à ses accessoires les relations
diplomatiques il se trouve que pour
l'instant les européens et la france en
particulier tiennent à maintenir le
canal diplomatique
pour continuer à dialoguer avec les
autorités russes ou plus haut niveau a
commencé entre chefs d'état et puis
rompre les
relations diplomatiques ça voudrait dire
ne plus porter assistance aussi à tous
les expatriés aux entreprises on
montrait vraiment d'un cran dans dans
les tensions parce que si les quelques
milliers de français expatriés à moscou
ont quand même besoin pour une
assistance pour de l'information des
services de l'ambassade s'il devait
plier bagages ont vraiment ce raid en
dans une tension sans précédent oui
parce que la france a quand même des
déliés encore très étroits avec avec la
russie s'emplir evans toujours qui
demander est ce qu'on pourrait bloquer
le trafic maritime dans nos ports et des
trois pour empêcher les navires us deux
circulait alors oui on pourrait enfin se
fait ça ferait partie des sanctions
dures on a vu il ya déjà eu des saisies
pas seulement des yachts mais de
quelques navires de des cargos de
marchandises parce que il était lié à
des entreprises qui sont explicitement
citée dans les sanctions il n'y a pas
que les oligarques il ya aussi leur
entreprise toute une série d'entreprises
publiques russes incertaine privé aussi
et donc la saisie de ce cargo qui venait
de rouen et qui a été saisi il ya une
dizaine de jours maintenant wavre entrer
dans le compte des sanctions déjà
établis très bien merci beaucoup fabrice
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin pour
faire sur cette sanction vous renvoie
aux autres articles du figaro gaz
aluminium la guerre d'ukraine pousse les
matières premières à de nouveaux records
parce que comme on l'a dit il ya
effectivement une flambée sur les prix
du gaz sur les prix du pétrole qui
devraient atteindre peut-être son niveau
historique
si possible merci à vous en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous nombreux à nous
suivre et moi je vous dis à bientôt pour
de nouveaux lives sur figaro live